are they an alternative to having a
friend are they like can you message
someone that you wish existed and who
doesn't or is this a an existing I think
the truth is let's see how people use
them often it's the it's the most sort
of unexpected use cases that really take
off but you will be able to you you'll
be able to bring in these uh I Persona
into a group chat so you have a mixture
of so if if you're a if you're a group
of friends who are organizing a a
holiday you'll be able to all together
chat with one of these a you know the
travel agent who is an AI Persona who'll
be able to give you recommendations in
that in that chat
group